not many men can weand my punch punch
obviously obviously for sure got a set a
got a set a ha on the spear
people yeah May
seals what have you like yeah this is
exciting what what training did you do
CrossFit I want some of the candy please
[Music]
yeah is Jeff here yet not yet he's
coming
M shower best thing I've ever had in my
life
okay
yes again the F in theid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby what
kind of what kind of whiskey Brown oh
yeah yeah bad bad bad yeah woke up every
day puffy as [__] at like 3:00 p.m.
thought that was normal yeah yeah no no
it's not good you got too much to do
you're too funny you're too very happy
thanks that's nice than you are you're
hilarious look at all this stuff look at
all this stuff we're moving yeah dude
which one of these is lion man it's a
good question Jeff it's a good godamn
good question I heard good things about
this Lion Man mhm and it doesn't hurt
any lions or anything they're they they
they grow that for free you're right
dude we shave the Lion's man is that
what it is no it's the adrenaline it
takes to shave the Lion's man then they
then they they take that adrenaline out
of your body and put it in to the
[__] they're selling adrenaline yeah
so it's not really Lion Man no it's the
adrenaline of the person shaving the
Lion's man okay terrible branding we
rolling we can roll now what yeah you
want the early on early stuff yeah want
the early stuff we're talking we're good
Holly Holm Holly Holm and Kayla Harrison
we're just looking at some uh potential
fights when you look at these do you
sexualize them or do you do you just you
look at it I find them attractive I I
find I had uh Helen moroles come she
she's a gold medalist in the Olympics
look up Helen R I'm so impressed with
her as a wrestler she you're a fight guy
she's just such a sick athlete but she's
also beautiful Chin's a fight guy what
how much muscle is too much muscle
that's a good question I I'm I'm a
sucker for um a booty and strong legs
what's your name again BR uh Helen
moroles but I'm also a sucker for
excellence but isn't a bootyos to be fat
supposed to be muscular see her she's
she is a stud and just super pretty but
also like you're talking about a gold
medalist in the Olympics it's [__]
ridiculous to be a gold medalist in
[__] in in in um I think she's
probably Greek but to be a gold medalist
in the Olympics is so hard at wrestling
it's so hard and she did it yes gold Met
look at that she's cying yeah I mean
come on she's number three in the world
and she's she's training again and uh I
don't know anyway I'm going who just
looked that up was that chin that's me
chin just threw a like on it you see
that look at that he goes oh this is a
here's her throw a like on it wait a
minute did she play the harp no one
plays
harp that is the strangest thing that
she would
do I don't know anyone that
plays give it a like yep Chin's liking
it all he's trying to get in her
algorithm no no I'm just just I can't
believe plays the harp that's a talent
I'm not accusing you of anything chin
you don't have to get so weird I can't
believe the harp wouldn't be a a you can
take that off okay but the harp wouldn't
be something you know you know what I
mean like if you're going to learn an
instrument it's like yeah who takes a
harp yeah I got to get a dolly to get my
harp in here yeah you know people go
what yeah yeah I mean like you want to
come up to my room and I'll play a solo
on my harp ding I would go up just to be
like there's no way you got a harp up
there does that come with angel wings
yeah how do you get a harp yeah yeah
where is do they sell is that in the
strings Department of a music store I
don't know but I just don't to me it's I
the accordion and the harp are not
instruments I would much use you
understand I'd be like listen I don't um
I don't care I am falling for her no no
you no you would fall for her the harp
yes the um the patriotism you don't see
that a lot none of the women in my life
seem to be too proud of our country CU
they don't know anything they go this
country is racist but then this girl
loves USA she's a gold medal and she
plays harp yeah why is it the people who
play harp and win gold medals are
Patriots but but girls who are trying to
be actresses all my only fans GS they
seem to hate America yeah that's weird
that's weird and they make money uh yeah
and also you know she plays the two she
you know she's she loves America but
then she also plays that's a good land
America and then she plays the harp
which is Heavenly you know two great
lands you're right and she has and yeah
you're right but the harp isn't really
something I can listen to even play if
played well for that for that long you
ever seen yeah put bring up lingling you
you want to see uh Lang Lang is it Lang
Lang the uh the great the panda bear
from the zoo lingling I think that's the
most famous lingling it is the lingling
No it's it's um it's the craziest no
it's Lang Lang I Lang Lang yeah the
Chinese uh the the Chinese
pianist and it's like I don't know can
we play this are we allowed to play this
let's see I I'll iter that it is Lang
Lang how do you know this I don't know
I'm awesome I I know if that yeah that's
the one that's the one watch watch how
just watch for a second watch this oh
man he's moving tickets too Lang this is
Mastery this is Mastery and you can't
believe a human being can do this see
people use autism as an insult but it is
a superpower look at is it might be it
is this isn't the one though all right
oh how many oh maybe it is it's just
Mastery listen if you don't respect it
the Obamas do yeah all right that's good
that's good quick Zoom to the Obamas
just appreciating piano I'm pretty sure
it's fake it's like edit it together
that's they probably did no they were
all in the audience but I mean you never
know what they're thinking right my
friend my friend had a concert at piano
concert and we all went he's a concert
pianist and I'm sitting there and my
buddy's sitting there and he just
started laughing so [__] hard I go
what are you laughing at he goes I'm
laughing at your bored energy you have
so much bored energy I was like I'm what
does bored energy mean it just means I
was I [__] I was like the guy was
amazing but I don't know what I'm
listening to so I was like but I like
that you like all these things when you
die I hope that they take your brain and
go what this is a weird one look at all
the [__] that's in here this guy knows
Lang Lang he's got that's not bored
energy you have an you have all these
wild things you know it's very
fascinating interested I'm interested in
in things like all things you seem to
have human potential I like I like uh I
like the big questions animals yeah
animals less animal Lang Lang you
shouldn't know Lang Lang yeah yeah I
like I like um I like reaching Beyond
myself I like things that are a mystery
to me the reason that you kind of go wow
when you see something beautiful like
that is because it's a mystery because
you don't know the the room is dark yeah
right so you don't there's but but
what's funny is as you as you learn
anything and you get good at it like if
he watched if he watched you do standup
yeah I guarantee he'd be like I don't
know how they do that I don't know how
he does that I don't think so you I get
this this is Jeff Dy no no well well
musicians actually my this is Jeff Dy
this is he's not coming up with any new
ground up there that's Jeff D is it
weird that you and Barack Obama have the
same favorite
pianist it is not weird cuz we're about
the same age now no you are not it's
weird to be the same age as president
you can't catch up to them not how age
Works probably true it's probably true
yeah do you play any
instruments um the harp no you don't
fluently no no did you play any I've
played the drums a little bit and I got
got obsessed with it I got obsessed with
it and then um and then I didn't have
time to practice but if you had let me I
would have practiced the drums four
[__] hours a day and maybe five if i'
had to let him like I was holding them
back no and then I took I took piano for
a while because I had written this play
and I wanted to learn how to play the
piano and I I hired this Chinese concert
pianist and and and this is going to
sound weird but she was she was making
me do the finger exercis in these
routine now okay so it say boxing or
martial arts you have to practice
sidekick back kick you have to practice
jab you have to practice your you have
to practice your combinations and you
have to do that for a long time before
you can understand how to put it all
together and usually you want to do that
when you're a kid if you want to learn
how to slip punches and stuff you have
to do it when you're young because you
know otherwise you're not going to see
stuff coming you're not going to
understand patterns the same idea with
piano where you have to lar like you do
these things there's a mechanical
there's a mechanic reality to learning
how to mess with Keith so I look at the
teacher and I go like this I go oh it's
too late for me yeah no it is and she
went I'm sorry Brian yeah I think so too
someone had me do in ninth grade she was
like all in this hand go Mary had a
little you know whatever and then she
had a different thing on this yeah and
she goes so start with this one and then
do this song and I go no like like it
just my brain couldn't figure it out and
I'm actually afraid if I take up like
martial arts or something that I'm not
going to be able to cuz I have no rhythm
so like when you do the 2 two one two or
whatever the hell it is I did like a
boxing class once a very entry level
like anybody they give you the gloves
and it's basically a big dance class I
couldn't even do that yeah but that's
because boxing's hard kicking and
punching are really hard it's different
it's a different well I could punch hard
but the rhythm of it I was going this is
too you're going to like this you you
like baseball love basball I stood at
the plate while they while these
Dominican pitchers One play for the
Dodgers the other play for the Yankees
one gu Frankie uh Frankie he's he's he's
just signed a big contract but anyway
with the Yankees can't remember but
anyway These Guys these guys were
throwing 98 mph pitches and my friend
said if you can touch the ball you're
you will get I will give you $1,000 yeah
zero chance and uh but I play a lot of
tennis so Daddy hit a foul ball off an
88 mile an hour um change up and then I
hit I got a piece of video of this I
have video it's not here this is
buit I'll show you the video it's one
but you you can see them per before we
start apology to all your the fans every
time I talk about baseball a bunch of
[__] [__] in the comments go oh
God if you want to skip all the baseball
talk every time he comes on sorry that I
they he asked me about baseball sorry he
he's an American
am yeah sorry about it well let's watch
this though I'm interested or at least
text to me so I can watch it later list
I'm not a basball video right it says
comedian
hitter I feel like I might be the Best
comedian hitter I think you
are he throws hard he used to be an
outfielder and now he's pitching I'm
going take it
easy these guys throw so hard dude
Pedro who's that guy that just said that
he's a pitcher Major leag P um okay now
see I'm holding the ball I
suck
that's pretty yeah but I it's lame but I
mean you know it had to be a change up
it was but I got another piece of a ball
uh take a little break if you guys want
to see me in Louisville or Oklahoma or
Tulsa uh go to brian.com guys the NFL um
I I'm I'm hearing from sonaz she's a lot
of people Brandon have got uh uh the
Ravens and the um 49ers I'm going I'm
going 49ers lion
well they're playing each hard to do
they're playing each other and that's
why I knew that you can tell I don't
know a lot about football but I'm
intrigued by this uh this this this
whole situation but Draft Kings sports
book uh is an official betting partner
of the NFL playoffs and it's bringing
you an offer that will make the playoffs
well possibly very profitable if you're
smart about it new customers can be $5
on any game and get 200 instantly bonus
bets okay so download draftking
Sportsbook app now use the code of
fighter new customers can bet just five
bucks to get 200 instantly in bonus bets
only on draftking Sportsbook with code
Fighter the crown is yours gambling
problem call 1 1800 Gambler or visit
www.1 1800 gambler. net in New York call
8778 hope Andy or text Hope NY 467 369
in Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call 8887 8
9777 or visit
ccpg please play responsibly on behalf
of Boot Hill Casino and Resort in Kansas
21 age plus oops 21 plus age varies by
jurisdiction void in Ontario bonus bets
expire 168 hours after issuance see
dk.com for eligibility and deposit
restrictions terms and responsible
gaming resources I don't wear any
underwear other than than meundies
actually if I can help it you you now
you have your favorite t-shirts I have
my favorite underwear and I think me's
like I think a lot of other people
copied me's style and the fabric they
use that's what I believe because I'm
telling you right now I never if if I
can help it that is my go-to underwear I
still have I should bring in some of my
my underwear that I've been wearing for
way too long but they last forever and
you just there's no point point and
throwing them out cuz they just they
always fit the same way they've got
styles for everyone from all black
Classics to fun expressive prints uh
they've got to look for everybody they
got size extra small which I definitely
don't take to 4 XL which I need um they
got versatile loungewear if you want to
lounge around it's not just about
underwear dude explore the lounge
collection featuring comfy joggers great
great gifts hoodies onesies um then then
they got the move me active wear
collection okay it's the softest act
active wear on the market it's unmatched
Comfort just try it soft as U it it's
basically it feels like it's like hey
can we get some chin chiler from a
three-piece set no all right let's
choose meundies all right breathable
it's stretchy um it's just unbelievable
uh it's also sustainably Source
materials so that's pretty wild and if
you're not happy with your first pair of
meundies it's on meundies but I
guarantee you're not going to kind of
look at I don't like these kick off the
New Year comfier than ever and get 20%
off your first order plus free shipping
at mean.com
fatk
tfatk that's
me.com
tfatk the fighter and the kid for 20%
off plus free shipping meundies comfort
from the outside in nice I'm impressed
but you know what it is I swear to God I
keep saying this but when you play as
much tenis I do you the ball's the same
size you you tennis is all timing so
it's not that crazy that I was able to
get my bat around keep my eye on it yeah
the point is # major leager # athlete #
baseball # allaround athlete # Supple
here's what Mo usually happens when you
get someone in the Box uh against a big
league pitcher even in the 80s yeah even
80 M hour people talk about like it's
not fast cuz it's not 100 even 80 mph
this is what it is crack and then you're
like what like it literally it's so
scary The Whiz off that ball like the
snap of the catcher Lea it's it's a big
deal but have you done it I'm sure you
can hit I can hit yeah but I mean I I've
never hit 90 I've never hit above 90 I
would imagine though you could hit have
you hit off a major league pit I've hit
some 80 80 M hour that's another thing
the ball goes a lot farther when it's
coming in that fast yeah so you put some
B on don't get me don't get it twisted
first of all you're talking about
beginner's luck in my case I get I bet
right now if I got it'd be a disaster
but more importantly those guys like I
can't get my bat around fast enough to
hit a 98 M I can't yeah I don't think
anyone it's a very unique group of
people even that even that ball I what I
was doing was I I was already I was
already starting to swing when he I was
like looking at it and I just kept my
eye you know but it's wild there's a
baseball player named Edgar Martinez he
used to do this exercise allegedly no
one knows if this is real but Edgar
Martinez claims that he would go in a
batter's box or sorry batter's a batting
cage that he had like at his house or
something and he drew on the baseball's
numbers and then he would just in the
badest he wouldn't hit him he would or
maybe he would hit him but he would like
go crack and they'd be like oh that was
number five and they'd be like yeah but
even in the spin he could tell you what
number was yeah allegedly yeah I don't
believe it but maybe I heard that story
when I was like 11 so I mean oh yeah The
Internet's been out since you know Edgar
Martinez might be asked about that and
he's like what I yeah they had stories
about that like with Ted Williams those
mythical stories that's like Ace Freely
when from Kiss when he play the guitar
his strings would smoke he was so good
oh that was back in the day when you
could say anything could just lie yeah
yeah my sister's a victim of this she'll
still lie and then we're like hey we
have the
internet she'll say it cuz she fools my
stupid parents or like our relatives
stupid parents yeah but she'll say stuff
she' be like you know Hitler was Jewish
I like no no he was Austrian like what
are you talking one of the most
documented guys of the last few hundred
years he wasn't crazy about she's like
no no he was Jewish I go Nikki you can't
just I promise you that that's not I
know that'd be very interesting if maybe
he was there there is a there are
historians uh historian by the name of
Brightman that's his last name uh I
think it's called breaking the silence
he wrote a book but he he there are
historians that said that Hitler didn't
know his father yeah and that his father
may have been Jewish on one side of his
family I don't know and so the hatred
for his father was kind of transl my
sister says I think she's confusing him
with Jesus cuz you know people always go
you know Jesus was Jewish and they oh
like like that's some epiphany or
something but I think my sister heard
someone smart say that about Jesus and
then now in Thanksgiving she just likes
to drop it like she's smart you know you
know Hitler was Jewish and I go Nikki no
and I have to be I look like the jerk at
the dinner table everyone's like going
why is Jeff disagreeing with Jeff why is
Jeff correcting the histor because it's
not accurate you know it's insane you
can't just make up stuff I just tried to
watch that Napoleon Movie you guys seen
this yeah how was it I'm too dumb for it
yeah yeah like it it was seemed inter
stuff but that like really preaching to
the choir they just start when he's like
a gunner for like the Army yeah and I'm
going I don't know any then they're like
they're like talking to each other I'm
not following was just too too much too
smart yeah Napoleon was you know sort of
a product of the French Revolution
that's the idea would be I had to know
all the stuff they didn't teach me
anything it wasn't like they started
when he was a little kid or anything
they just start with this guy and then
all of a sudden they're like shooting
people and then someone goes good job
shooting those people and I'm I look at
the girl I'm with go am I supposed to be
following this I have no idea what's
Happening Here do you didn't even tell
me what goddamn country this is
in have you seen any good movies uh I
saw the iron claw you go see you're
amazing cuz you'll go see movies and
games I don't do any of that [__] why
not I I think because I I don't know I
mean maybe I don't I'm not interested
maybe that I'm not interested in most
movies I like anything an old man would
like yeah soup you like soup I love a
walk yeah I walk I see a park bench I go
hell yeah I'm about to sit on that like
I like a sit and talk with someone you
can relax and you're not in a rush to go
anywhere you're in the Moment movie
theater's fun I like these old things I
like an old thing so when you're you're
on the road you'll you can you'll go do
something like all oh me and my openers
we'll walk all over the joint and you
just walk yeah yeah see I'm I I'm if I'm
not reading I'm probably writing or
thinking really yeah I spend all my time
alone what are you reading right now and
then I'm working out I I watched the
iron Club what are you reading
I'm reading um I'm reading another
number of books but oh you're like Cat
Williams 3,000 books this
year that what he said that crazy person
he said uh he said uh I'm reading in
multiple languages I've read 3,000 books
this year okay well that's 10 books a
day cat I know everyone's already
crunched the numbers and made fun of him
for this but out of all the things he
said I found that to be the most
Preposterous that is pretty Preposterous
we're letting them off the hook for
3,000 books a year what are you AI cat
you I can barely read I can barely read
and I listen to books all the time I
probably listen to like about a book
every week and a half that's good cuz
some of them are longer so it takes me
book are you listening to um what I do a
lot of self-help stuff but uh like the
one I'm reading right now is VC uh V Ram
Swami's book woke Inc yeah what do you
think so just it's good I mean it's a
lot of the same stuff like John mcer
already covered in his book like John M
A lot of these other books I've heard
but it's good and I like VC so as I got
I'm also going to get to like be on
panel with him on gutfield so I want to
like know what he's about that's great I
like him yeah I do too but that's great
I didn't know you were political so
you're you're interested in these things
I'm a 2001 liberal which means I'm a
Republican and some people are Nazi I'm
right with you I'm right with you I
didn't change any of my views yet here I
found myself in a Cowboy head and old
people going I get yeah yeah I'm
literally just all I am is traditional I
just call me crazy I believe in the
Constitution and maybe that you can't
just say you're a woman and be a woman
like I don't that's what makes us Nazis
now is that I go I just want to say that
I don't think men can have their periods
and they're like give us
Barabas crucify him you know it's insane
true it's it's but it's eight people on
Twitter and they might might not even be
real I don't know and I I'm going to
block all eight yeah that's how I feel
did you see this uh thing that Carrie
Lake that Republican senator I mean
Republican operative came to her if this
is new and he said she recorded he said
he said uh he said look we don't want
you to run they're powerful forces and
just take a pause and uh give us a
number and we'll pay you oh I like that
and she was like you want me to not run
because he go yeah we just you know look
at that chairman resigns you ever afraid
you're going to botch that someone says
you put any number on this
chick we we we'll take care of it just
you resign from this run and take a
little break we'll give you however much
you want and I'm like all right how 10
grand they're like yeah 10,000 yeah of
course yeah yeah afraid you'll botch the
situation well they have she goes I
wouldn't do it for a billion dollars
good for her yep and he he just sounds
he sounds like he's out of a movie he
sounds literally like you got to listen
to the tape I was like are you kidding
me right now that's who why do they want
her out of it why do they want her to
take a pause what's the I think that
they didn't want her to compete with
their candidate of choice who's their
candidate of choice I don't know I don't
know who they wanted but uh interesting
it's really interesting man I was like
that is
strange um I feel like I'm in a dream I
feel like I'm underwater because I I was
I did a corporate gig in Vegas yeah and
then uh my friend Tim Kennedy said uh
you know Tulsi gabard yeah I love tulsy
she's got F time I with her now oh she's
great she was on she was at my show uh
and and both of them are like you have
to come to our show uh you have to come
to CrossFit tomorrow and I'm like what
time they're like 6:30 we're leaving at
0500 they made you get up at 6:30 I get
at 5 I had to get up 550 now I hate
working out early too and I can't sleep
if you tell me I'm going to have to wake
up early I can't sleep all night so I'm
tossing and a turning and then I'm
working out with these Navy Seals and
Green Berets I dude you know I it was
the 40 minute it's a 40-minute workout
so now I'm like I'm like I'm on the
plane like this of yeah your whole body
want and I'm Dreaming like this yeah you
got to come here and talk now like this
is you're worth it well that's ni your
face is energized let me tell you I woke
up this morning at 8:00 a.m. to do a
9:00 a.m. yoga and I was like what's
wrong with me that's outrageous this is
too early my body's going what are you
doing dude like this is too early I like
a 4M work at least yoga isn't burpees
and and an aerodine bike and box jumps
these chicks think they're they listen
what it is gross that I call this yog
yog it's gross that they call it yoga
it's Power Yoga it's they shouldn't even
be able to have hot yoga on the side of
the building it's weights and dance
class to a bunch of Rihanna songs and
they're going aren't we doing yoga I'm
so enlightened he no you're doing this
is like a military workout if everyone
was hot if everyone was hot and gay it
is terrible a lot of Taylor Swift too
I'm sick of that I can't stand I'm sorry
I I I don't like that music political at
this point she's playing the music I'm
going out of this [__] yeah I I don't
want to hear it I'm just I'm too old to
listen to Taylor Swift it's a lot it's
also the all the girls are like singing
it in class like that'll annoy you real
fast 20 chicks all singing it at once
I'm going God damn so it's just you and
20 chicks but you're CutiePie so they
must all be like they ignore me and they
I don't want to be seen in here it's
like well really barely wearing any I
feel like you're the kind of guy that
gets a lot of uh smiles from gals um not
in yoga class no yeah that's uh they
don't like that yeah they like want you
to pretend like they're not there you
know but when you're when you're you
disagree yeah I I I'm going to go with
Ry on this one you're getting a lot of
smiles yeah they're making sure they're
wearing their matching sets a lot of
matching sets 65 funny goodlooking I I
try to smile at him like I'm I turn to
him I go
like yeah you know give him one of those
if you do that that's a little bit you
look a little bit like you look touched
good pose you know stuff like that yeah
yoga compliments good breath great great
yeah great um you're getting you're SAS
seem like they're super aligned yeah
good posture good posture she's going
stop talking to me right you got the you
got the posture of a Chita banana the
opposite I'm using that tomorrow Great
Bend great back bend you got good bends
baby I'm I'm I'm doing a I'm doing a
[__] um my buddy played pro football
and he's first time doing you know yoga
great athlete but like it's yoga and
there was this insanely beautiful um
insanely this is 20 years ago this
insanely beautiful yoga teacher named
Shiva Ray Shiva Ray like from Mortal
Kombat yeah look up Shiva Ray and she
taught in Venice and she she's like it's
we're in this but when you she would do
this when yeah when she would do the do
the thing like she's beautiful now and
when she was younger she was like you
know insane you know like look at her
now she's probably 50 and she's
gorgeous yeah so when she was like 30
she was like you know just this insanely
hot beautiful woman well she didn't do
bickram did she no she was a she's a
serious Yogi like she that bickram
turned out to be a rapist oh yeah you
guys know about that yep yep he got very
badly mewed he uh still got his name on
the side of the building he's but he's
hiding in India I think but anyway yeah
but he drove around in a rollsroyce two
Rolls-Royce everything else so so you
see her she's very pretty M and and
where when she would show up real yogis
would be there and they'd be like it was
another guy named Max stum saying they
like the real yogis oh she had a cult
following yeah so me and my buddy couple
jerk offs in Venice we're single dudes
we're just looking at the girls I here's
yoga but I just like I was like let me
try this but also the girls are so
[__] hot the guy next to you is
floating like how is this so she ends up
doing some crazy pose where she's got
her ass near and my buddy doesn't
realize it and he just goes like this he
goes he goes look at her ass nice
everybody just goes like that and I was
like oh no yeah you bad you showed your
true colors yeah and then I dated a girl
from there who was so [__] hot she I
couldn't believe she like me I was like
what the [__] is going on but I was I
was a young cutie I was like 30s in my
30s seems like a different time but I
was I was a cutie and um it wasn't Jeff
D but I was cute and and girls you know
and and and then I I broke up with her
because she told me that um I should
build a shrine in my living room to the
people I admire so I said I was like oh
no I was like like George Carlin yeah
she was from Switzerland and I thought
she was and she goes I said what and she
goes you should um build a you should
build a shrine to I was talking about
Marlon Brando she said you should build
a shrine to Marlon Brando and pray to it
and I was like I don't know what the
[__] is going on here that's kind of
weird yeah I got to get the [__] out of
here not even kind of it's it's weird
yeah and she liked me cuz we had sex and
then she goes she goes yeah she goes
and she she just had to come over and
talk you [__] me up cuz we had text
and I you know I was like I Fel I felt
so bad but I was like and I don't know
how to tell her I I I I I I said I was
moving to New York I think CU I didn't
want to hurt her feelings yeah just good
well because she was such a nice person
but also she was so dumb that she'd
believe it yeah I just didn't want I I
knew I couldn't honor the relationship I
didn't want to make her feel like you
know I'm not going to go down that road
and then then all of a sudden when when
she's that kind of per I just can't
right and what if you ran into her again
well that's that's what I you got to
roll the dice you know I got I'm just
visiting it's weird I keep running into
you here yeah yeah so yeah oh oops keeps
happening yeah yeah I still come to this
coffee shop every morning I just live in
New York she's going I'm I think I'm on
to this guy no cuz I fly at night I go
have to go back and forth yeah it's it's
exhausting this coffee worth it am I
right she was going what is going on
with this guy Fu worth it
uh yeah the yoga something about a girl
getting fit and going to yoga class
makes her think that she is spiritually
enlightened yeah you know it's very
exhausting well try being my age try
being my age when young people say
things like all you got to do is get
your nutrition right and everything
falls into place does it or you know or
just yeah yeah for me I'm just walking
the spiritual path yoga I don't know why
people just don't you got you got a
26-year-old telling me about Health
eating a handful of berries and you like
hey you don't know shut up you're 26
yeah she should be like you the secret
is just be 26 yeah just be 26 you can
eat anything you want yeah yeah yeah try
being 57 shut up already I I can't stand
this stuff well they'll just like start
the class they' be like um you know this
like if you are having trouble setting
the motivation here's a powerful reading
and it'll just be some music quotes or
something I'm just going Jesus Christ
like it's very it's if that is something
that's moving them I love that like I
support everyone searching for their but
if you're going to share it it you
should know that's pretty vulnerable oh
yeah like that they're so fine being so
vulnerable about this stuff I'm like you
guys sound like idiots well but there's
also something so so when you talk about
being spiritual right yeah so you have
these young these young people are like
I'm spiritual I'm walking the spiritual
path or you know I'm really okay um the
problem is that that there's there's
something called worship without
sacrifice and so if you're really
spiritual what do you SA sacrificing
what is the price you're paying that
would be the idea behind right it's fine
to be spiritual awesome because you have
plenty to eat and you're really pretty
and they're in there cuz they're vain
that's why they like yoga class they
want abs they want to sweat out all the
wine they drank the night before they
say the same stupid [__] oh I'm like a
grandma I go to bed at like 8 so we
think oh she's not a [__] oh great
she's going to bed early and they say
try little things like I'm not religious
but I'm spiritual and anything you
haven't heard of they all Embrace isn't
that beautiful like a Native American
will spit in their face and they'll be
like oh this must be part of their
culture it's beautiful but if you say oh
me too I love Jesus and they're like oh
my God Jesus he must be RAC Rel that's
so patriarchal it's the same girl I've
met that girl a thousand times yeah have
you heard like the girls will be like
well that's misogynist and then the guy
goes do you know what misogynist means
spell or from the river to the Sea they
were asking all these people that were
talking about pal free Palestine from
the river to the Sea and they asked them
what river and what sea and they
literally like well I I'm just saying
that I don't believe in genocide oh let
me guess you don't believe in genocide
and what else you do you not like
slavery God you really make a stand yeah
God you really we thought it was like
window to the wall till sweat drops down
our but it's it's aane it isn't about an
actual window and an actual wall there's
not an actual
c yeah there is so you're a good person
are you against kicking babies in face
too is that the other thing you're
against yeah want you make a big sign
yeah you sound like a great person yeah
I can't I have this joke I haven't done
it in a while actually I've never even
done it on stage but I was like but I
was like for me to like make a sign and
March yeah I don't know what you I I'm
not getting in the street like I and my
sign would probably say something like
ug cuz I don't cuz it's or it's
complicated every time I see someone
with a sign I think to myself how stupid
humans must be oh my God oh God a whole
sign you guys got together with signs
this is the best idea we got when during
the black lives matter marches and the
stuff when when after George Floyd I'm
in Beverly Hills and there's some chick
with a mask on on the street and she's
white yeah and she held up a sign that
said all cops are bastards yeah and I
was like you are the biggest piece of
[__] you are so dumb and you're so dumb
and you're so dumb and you're such a
piece of [__] I'm like you are just a
[__] zero and there was a cop over
there some dude some cop who's keeping
everybody safe making sure and and and
and and he can't even shoot her a dude I
was like somebody [__] hit her with a
car she was the worst but it's like it's
just so free it's so free for you to say
some dumb [__] like that that's what's
amazing is all these signs just that
You' think that there'd be anything
would be more productive than you just
putting it on a sign and getting
together with your friends who agree
with you can't even when I agree with
the thing I just go this did nothing
sign corner there's a corner of people
with signs I got so embarrassed after
the George George Floyd thing nobody was
looking at the actual stats cuz in in
the when George Floyd was actually
killed um the the there were there were
10 million arrests and of that nine
unarmed black men had been killed at 10
million we could fit them all on a shirt
that's so incredible that's how you know
was not as much as white guys cuz we
knew all their names we learned all
their names we were able Hassan Minaj
you look up a clip he'll tell you all
the [__] names in about 10 seconds
but that's you we know all the names
that's amazing memorize all the white
guys that were shot in the same year by
police uh I bet you couldn't do it you'd
have to but nobody looks at that and
then I had there was just all these
white guys in Venice and I saw them and
they all they all kneeled and raised
their fists and they had they they were
doing it in front I'm trying to get my
coffee and they're doing it in the
street I'm like hey guys listen all you
[__] dudes from Toledo and wherever
else you came here to be actors and now
you're doing this weird thing because
you're just you're not even looking into
anything it was just I get soed I would
uh you know everyone says like you
everyone should have to work in a
restaurant people always go oh everyone
should have to serve tables everyone
should have to wait tables once in their
life we have such compassion for like
servers you know yeah we should all have
to be with a cop for a week oh yeah that
that's what everyone should have to do
is go see what it's like to be a police
officer they go into someone's worst day
of their life if you had to call the
cops it's probably the worst day of your
life or at least close every second they
go into someone's worst day that's right
even if it's an easy one where it's like
oh this is a no-brainer that guy hit
this lady let's arrest it wears on you
man yeah you just slowly go man I can't
believe I'm doing this for $40 my
neighbor was a motorcycle cop and he'd
come back every day and he would just
play the guitar CU he was like [__] it
and I was like what's up he goes dude
the amount of negative energy I get all
day long they [__] hate me blow my
brains out I was like I did like that
after uh BLM the police were trying
tring a little harder to get along you
know yeah I did like that like I was at
my coffee shop this is lockdown lockdown
so like you had to go in with your mask
order wait outside and they and I
remember we were all out there and me a
few of my buddies and these police uh
men came in and they were like good
morning and I was like hey good morning
and they like say to like the little
baby like hey little baby and I was
going these guys really trying to yeah
yeah yeah step it up well they were they
were on their heels and and uh it is
true though the I've T I talked to a
bunch of black dudes about it like
privately and I was like do you feel
different and they did they every one of
them was like dude I mean look feel
different about what like like when when
cops I never worry about cops yeah but
every one of them does and they're not
they're not liberals they not well
they've been taught that but they're
black guys who have had their own
experience so they'd be little things
like that my buddy said to me one time
he goes well when I see cops if I lower
I turn my music down okay or I put on I
put on glasses no I'm talking about when
they drive by them next to or I'll put
on glasses that make me look like I'm
you know I don't know educated or
something like that everybody all every
black guy I talked to when I pressed him
was like I I get nervous because I've
had my own experiences okay and so that
that's interesting I I don't that's not
I call it being gangster fluid yeah
that's here's the thing she can shake
her head all she wants this here's the
thing when we will look at rappers or
like rap culture right yeah they look
cool don't they they they look cool with
the the Raiders hat and the chains and
the no smiles and the tattoos and the
muscles that looks cool yeah we like
that it's edgy it's it's it's it's Thug
it's we we love it now if that is your
look yeah there's a reason that
intimidate it's going to work against
you if if some people walk by something
gain something lost that's the thing so
yes it is a cool look but then people go
can you believe they just think we're
thugs when you're dressed like that yes
we assume you're thugs it has an
intimidating presence it has a marijuana
esque uh presence it has this this like
tough presence to it now if there's like
seven black guys wearing like baggy old
church suits from the south I'm not as
tepid around you're just talking about
pattern recognition that's all it is if
and with white guys have hoodies on and
like tattoos on their face and they
they're dressed in this same culture I'm
very yeah tepid around them too so I
think cops learn these things and I am
not saying cops are perfect and there is
plenty of bad cops and I we got to get
those [__] out of there and there's
plenty of cops that are lazy and there's
plenty of I'm not like on anyone's one
side but this whole idea of like oh am I
just a thug I'm like look at what you're
wearing yeah yes you look like a thug do
you look cool yeah but you don't look
you don't look like someone I'd be like
good morning fellas like no you don't
get both and that's what they want they
want to be they want to be gangster like
fluid they're all tough they're all
tough they're all tough and then someone
treats them like they're tough and
they're like you're racist for he's like
no that's not racist it's what you're
putting out there yeah do you ever get
treated like a like Jack all the time I
like that jacket I get treated how I
look look at this [__] oh this guy
tall and hands probably has the World
opening up for him so easy he's got the
key to the city I had a woman just the
other day she goes look at you straight
white man with all your privilege and I
was like
jealous jelly someone's jealous you want
to kiss me as what you I know what
you're doing over doing you like me ugly
lady
you you criticize me cuz you w me that's
it she's going oh I'm
fat well I that that's a quote she did
no I'm fat you got curbs uh what do you
got Chen let's do some let's do some
current events let me just do one thing
can I make a phone call real quick yeah
let's take a break I have noticed a
problem uh just not like I noticed but
like I'm noticing a theme at least that
people are a little too willy-nilly
about that kind of thing what's that um
like like so for example there's a
documentary called Curry and cyanide or
cyanite in curry and it's about this
woman who like poisoned a family member
right and then the person died eyes we
back on all right cool uh was that
recording we're good yeah we're okay so
the uh so like she poisoned her family
and the person dies and they like they
ask the police in hindsight like 20 30
years later like why didn't you guys
look into that they're like well she had
just lost a family member you know we
don't want to be disrespectful to the
family and start poking around in their
personal business and then they ask the
family members why didn't you have the
police look into this they go well we
were all mourning the death of a family
member you know we didn't want want the
police coming in and poking around so
then this lady learned oh that's a
pretty good deal whenever someone annoys
me I'll just poison them to death she
did it to like six family members what C
I think it's like five or six it took
that sixth person before someone started
asking questions of like these deaths
are all kind of similar but they could
have probably saved five other deaths if
they just looked into it the first time
this like do the work it was a woman in
India who was uh what a crazy
[__] she had lied about uh
yeah Jolly Joseph and that's another
thing is um at least in the documentary
they really painted the picture of like
well women aren't to be disrespected
like that you know you don't go You Know
This Woman's sad she Lov psycho you
don't go around going hey lady like they
would in their culture even maybe just
back then maybe now I don't know much
about Indian culture but in India they
also were like a woman would never do
this you women are right almost like in
a really sweet sexist way of killed who
men are murderers not these nice women
who make babies well she's obviously a
complete sociopath oh for sure she
killed who her mom her dad she killed
first her father-in-law then her
mother-in-law then her husband so she
and then the wife of the man she wanted
to marry next and then like just it was
just anyone who got in her way oh so oh
my God terrible lady wow yeah and then
when they like re Exum what's it called
when they dig up a body is that an Exum
I think so they dig up the bodies just
to like baby basically Pro pin it on her
that like these bodies were cyanide
poisoned or whatever I don't know if I
said that right wow then the whole
nation was like this is uh this is
blasphemy to dig up a body this is
disgusting let this poor leave this poor
woman alone she's lost her family now
you're digging up their bodies it's like
someone's got to do the work yeah
someone has to do some looking some
poking take some samples yeah all right
take some samples under the nails no one
gets caught if everybody just goes well
let's be respect
no they'll they'll they'll they'll
they'll dig you up yeah they'll dig you
up if there's a problem they should find
it that's crazy though but American uh
nightmare which is a good name by the
way American Nightmare yeah cuz you know
the American dream is such a fun
expression to call something the
American Nightmare is pretty cool God
you can bring somebody in your family
and they're a total psycho and they kill
they kill everybody like you ever afraid
someone's going to kill you um uh no not
really I mean I've had that but well
here's the secret you want to uh not be
killed not you you're a woman oh I don't
have any solutions for you as a man to
not be killed just don't get a life
insurance policy oh is that right I've
watched a lot of snap that's all it is a
guy acts like a guy which is not good
typically and then uh cheats on his wife
or he's going to leave her whatever and
she's like well I'm not going to be
humiliated and I get a bunch of money
and I could be a widower and I get to
keep everything that
I think that happened to my friend I
think she was trying yeah I think she
was going to try to kill him you're
kidding yes what are their
names yeah it was very very shocking she
turned out to be a complet married a
long time she turned out to be a
complete psycho have you ever wanted to
kill someone yes yeah yes I'm trying to
think there was a time where I wanted to
kill a lady but uh and I was like I just
thought about it briefly yeah I uh
couldn't do it yeah I wouldn't do but at
time that you'd want someone killed
there was an hour or so where I I don't
think you escape it I don't think you
get away from it you know well I never
would be able to do it or myself no not
I wouldn't do it you know I suppose I
can kill my for my country or something
but I wouldn't kill like if somebody had
yeah I mean you I'm sure if you did
something to my kids or something God
forbid then you you want to kill the
person but then like anything in life
you've got other kids and you know it's
it's a thing what about you guys you
ever wanted to kill someone
no no never uh listen all of us have a
[__] serial killer in us I'm admit to
it all of us have a murderer in us and
we I mean I never had something Happ
where I'm like if that person [__]
died right now oh yeah I drive on the LA
freeway every day of course I want to
kill somebody doesn't count it's a very
morning television answer right there
yeah that was a very political answer
I've never actually AOC over here listen
I drive on the LA freeway never actually
wanted to kill somebody like no I've
never wanted to kill someone I wanted
someone
Dead uh yeah I mean I couldn't do it
there are people that if they died there
are plenty of people I think that if
they died the world would be a better
place so so if a if a car hit them on a
if the car [__] you know killed them
or say I I think the world would be a
better place there are some people who I
believe that I that I that I yeah that
that that should probably die for all of
our sake I'm glad we're talking about
this cuz I've got my buddy was like he
was going how could you say that I was
talking about someone the other day a uh
comedian I said if this chick died
tomorrow I wouldn't care and my friends
are like Jesus Jeff and I go what we're
not friends she offers nothing to me she
says terrible things about me she's what
I wouldn't care if she died and my
friends's like that's absolutely
terrible and I was like why people die
all the time yeah I'm sure if I died she
wouldn't care she might lie and pretend
that she does but she would probably be
fine if I died here's the thing
you can't go around caring about
everyone that dies you you'd be in a
constant state of mourning well I got
one better when you say we have to the
world we need to make the world a better
place that's a fancy way of saying some
people need to die yeah you know what do
you think our military is there for
there are people that you know and if
you're listening thinking no I care when
people die no you don't if you had a
feature on your phone that beeped every
time a someone died you would turn that
off so fast you'd be like how do we
silence the death
beep I was just with a bunch of guys who
you know and GS who their job is they go
oh there are a bunch of people that want
to do some bad [__] to America or do
some bad [__] out there and then they
they are the guys who go well we have to
get that person because they're a high
value Target and they somebody has to
pull that trigger gayen
Epstein she [__] died I wouldn't care
jlan I don't know how to say her name
wait her name is jiz
G it's galain I think it's gal galain
what a weird name H anyways that [__]
could die yeah wouldn't care about her
super pretty when she was younger really
yeah I think my Ty when she was around
14 oh oh my Jeffrey couldn't handle
himself he goes look at this one yeah
this when she was young jizan I never
understood why she she could have ran
away and she stayed in no she she was
part of the crime when she was younger
she was gorgeous her dad she was oh yeah
that's what the guy does they like draw
you in by making you feel special and
then you end up doing all the work for
them well you know he never uh left her
so maybe she was special yeah she was uh
sure cheated on her with all those
children but he didn't her dad was
killed by um mad cuz her dad worked for
mad for Israeli intelligence oh really
yep well anyways if that lady died I
wouldn't
care there's got to be more examples
yeah yeah there are a lot of people that
could die and and be
like you know my neighbor
Rick man I wouldn't bother me at all
good old Rick yeah that guy and no one's
going to Care my neighbor
Rick Rick the dick I don't know why I
tried to convince you guys that you'd
want some people dead but I feel like
well no I get it it's very some good
example thinking about it now I got some
in my head what do you got for uh
current events chin all right chin uh
before current events uh first of all
Jeff thank you so much for filling in
you always like you know you always save
the day last minute so you're super
awesome we appreciate you so much yeah
and also if we can give uh prayers out
best wishes to Brendan yeah yeah yeah
yeah um Brendan's baby Billy goes into
um surgery tomorrow and uh it's it's a
very extensive surgery it could be up to
six hours I don't want to say too much
that he hasn't said but um thoughts and
prayers and um so stressful when it's a
kid yeah it's his two-month old baby and
um you know they're they're running a
lot of tests they don't quite know
what's wrong yet and you know man it's a
it's a very heavy time so uh we love you
buddy if you need anything I know
Brennan's got a blessed people in his
life and he's got a lot he's surrounded
by a lot of great people he got a good
team and he's got a lot of money but uh
lot of M yeah I'm just saying he's got a
really good life and there's not many
things I can offer him that he doesn't
got and so you give him so much support
so that's that's that's all I can you
know I'm just saying we're sending you
positive vibes and I love you if you
need anything let me know and by the way
when anybody's going through something
like this if you don't call them they'll
never forget it yeah it may seem like
they don't need it but text them call
them you know anybody who's in your life
that's going through something because
it means a lot to them whenever you go
through chaos um if if if people don't
reach out to you you you go okay I got
it okay I got you also I just brought up
the money thing CU it's like if he if he
needed it that that's that's the time
yes I'd give you whatever you need man I
I don't have much to offer except
Positive Vibes you're about to because
you just won the lotto yes there it is
guys and now surprised just [__]
dollar bills totally inappropriate like
squid games yeah squid games is great
because uh you get a ton of money at the
end and you just killed a bunch of other
homeless people or people that need
money yeah by the way another person we
love is Brian K it's his birthday oh my
God my God I love you guys look at this
a little test book you are that is so
cute really appreciate that a cupcake
and a lab dance you're so nice can't
believe you're going to do that and a
what and a lap dance so should we do a
little quick song oh yeah let's do it
dude all right happy birthday where's
she at where's the birthday sing Happy
Birthday to you Brian K happy birthday
to
youy birthday
dear
happy birthday to you me yeah buddy now
the Black
Version that's what they always say all
my black friends and then they sing it
what's that cupcake this is what kind is
this well your fingers in it it's yours
now all right it's the Jeff die kind
love it Jeff do you cook thank you s
thank you I am the chin andaz snaz
that's a great outfit on you thank you I
thought her name was schnaz no
schnaz don't give the internet ideas
Jack got her schnaz is sonaz is schnaz
in in farsy is it no I don't
know um no I don't cook in fact I'm
looking for I hope that my person out
there my perfect match Cooks cuz I do
not and it's embar are you on the are
you on the prow are you on the lookout
no I guess I'm always looking or
whatever but I'm not really but um God
I'm I'm it's so bad I eat soup all the I
just have a lot of soups and then at
night when I don't want to like heat up
a pot of soup I have cereal which is
really just cold
soup yeah you eat cereal love cereal
cereal and soup cereal and soup there's
a lot of that and anything you can like
just kind of have around your house like
a banana or an orange or something you
know just boring what kind of soup from
a can yep chunky really you know like
what's that what's that brand what you
evered C Campell yeah you evered to make
soup from scratch no okay sounds hard
it's not I had Mis Sushi plays last
night that was pretty good yeah um you
don't know much about food you're not
food I'm the worst yeah I like eating
food but I just don't know how to make
it I have no interest in learning how to
make it yeah a lot restaurant do you
spend money on food or yeah yeah yeah I
like well especially that's like company
based but what do you do do you eat like
you know do you eat thank you my love
thank you very much what do you do you
eat like thank you are you are you
boring are you boring with your food are
you do you eat uh
like uh like just hamburgers and pizza
you simple guy um I like it all I like
everything yeah yeah I'm not too
picky give us some uh current events
thank you for that all
right feel why is the Tesla on top of
here cuz cuz I drive one yeah that's it
you just yeah hey there's a lot of
thought put into that it's cute I just
wondering if maybe there's some secret K
Harrison is a beast so I love Dana White
one UFC uh has signed Kayla Harrison and
has announced she will be taking on
Holly Holm at UFC 300
guys so thoughts let's going to peek at
her huh the thoughts are that Holly Holm
is gonna have her hands full with Kayla
Harrison Kayla Harrison is so scary and
so big and so strong I don't even know
how Kayla gets down to 45 no no it's
going to be
35 around 75 175 that's what we heard
she a that cheating well Kayla is was
that a bronze medalist in Judo I think I
think gold was she a gold medalist I
don't know which is insane if she was a
gold medalist it seems like cheating
that I can just do all this stuff to get
down to super low weight stand on a
scale and then immediately just start
putting it back on and then fight like
even if it's hours later you could
still gold gold do that seem a little
weird she got a gold in London in in the
Olympic Games in London and Rio de
janiro that's so insane and in Tokyo
who's older oh she's a freak Holly's way
H's older yeah so this chicken to be
younger and bigger seems Kayla's 33
Holly's 42 see this [__] so Kayla
Harrison's a crazy judoka that's super
hard to do bet all your money on her
well Holly Holmes is very used to
fighting a lot of people and Judo is not
MMA it's very different so but I would
say that the so I've heard some
interesting things though no maybe it's
not Kayla Harrison yeah what does Dana
White have to say about it or is this
announcing it oh I see announcing yeah
Kayla Harrison is bring her up like you
should see you know she's a she is such
a specimen I will say if I had a little
Yogi Shrine for all the celebrities I
liked in my house Dana White would be
one of them I love that guy yeah look at
her I don't know how she's going to get
down to 35 the getting down to 35 is
going to be she can get down to 35 for a
couple
seconds uh you know she's she weighs she
weighs more than I do she has muscles in
her face oh yeah dude you're talking
about a very strong athlete crazy strong
now she looks She's yeah yeah the
question becomes I don't know how she um
what was that pick is she topless in
that picture I don't know I think that's
photosh no go over left yeah no oh yeah
yikes yeah that's a that's she's a
strong gal she's a very strong you're
talking about Olympian you're talking
about a gold medalist that's very
difficult to pull off yeah so packan
whoever you are fighting and but Holly
Holm she's yeah I'm going to bet 35 lb I
think Kayla Harrison's coming in the
problem is that Kayla I don't know how
much she trains but for her to suck down
to 35 is a lot it's a lot huge amount
yeah it's a lot so we'll see interesting
well I I'm a big Holly Hol
fan um this chick looks like she's going
to win though she get to be younger and
big she's got to drop a ton of weight
though which is going to be tough for
her CU she's never so the hard part is
just her getting to that scale at that
way I think so yeah and then she's just
going to gain it
I think that beat that ass and then get
another have a day but I I stood next to
her and I could have sworn like just she
would just destroy me and I'm 200 lb I'm
62 63 would destroy me when I when I
stood next to her 100% well no you so so
I think she can she can she she can she
can hit so [__] hard but Holly um is
also this is an introductory fight cuz
Holly is sort of older now and and she's
going to have a hard time so they're
kind of giving this is Kayla Harrison's
breakthrough so what's going to happen I
think is that she's being Holly's being
sort of like you know they're saying
we'll give you we'll give you a veteran
who's been probably G to retire soon
yeah and this came out of nowhere too it
was like super random cuz she was from
the pfl um what is that the Pacific
Football League yeah this is what
happened this is super super confusing
uh so there's like a group of friends
that did a Curry woman get in there with
her Cy that's probably what happened
Jolly Jama or whatever her name is nuts
yeah so there was a a Chief's party with
some friends and then uh three of the
friends somehow ended up dying and
freezing outside the the place right did
they pass out and freeze so no the the
investigation is still going on but what
they know so far is like three of the
guys were outside and they froze to
death and the guy that hosted I think
the guy that hosted the party was on the
couch sleeping he passed out before his
friends went outside I think they might
have all gotten drunk and these guys
passed out here's the thing though so BR
so the apparently the guy that hosted
the the party he was sleeping for two
days in a row on a couch inside two days
in a row that's unusual yeah so they
they were gone for two days and one of
the fiances of the guys that passed away
she didn't get any text messages back or
calls back so she broke into the house
and found out that her fiance was you
know passed out and died in in the
backyard the fu so they're trying to
figure it out and apparently the guy uh
the guy that owns the house or or rented
the house he's like an HIV scientist so
the families of the people that die
right yeah it's going to be G I don't
know that but I'm thinking the same
thing je please Jeff do you mind I'm
being briefed Sir Jeff I'm GNA ask you
to please keep your point of view damn
it Jeff when you're at my maturity level
it's very hard to keep Jeff please we're
having this is an adults conversation my
bad all right keep going yeah so the
families think that the the the three
people were you know drugged and put
outside but they don't know EXA why
exact you know the ACT actual reason why
but it's just so weird all of it's weird
why would three people outside also
here's the thing too I have no one in my
life guys like literally I have a lot of
friends people like me but no wife no
girlfriend not even any romantic
interests and if I'm gone for longer
than an hour everyone is like where's
Jeff di what's Jeff di my man is going
what the [__] he should have been at the
how does anyone I don't know that's
engaged just not hear from their partner
for something something even a night
you'd be like he's cheating on me blown
up his phone I don't understand I think
they were they were drugged by the
scientists that's what the families are
thinking and they're trying to like yeah
right this guy this sounds like uh I
think it's exactly what happened our
comedian friend who had all those guys
die in the same houses or it sounds like
that oh I was just asleep and I woke up
and all my friends were dead
well that was fenel that's what I'm
saying this sounds like fenel that
sounds like maybe they were doing they
don't want to admit they were doing yeah
they might blow and then there was
something and then instead they're like
we froze you're like well yes I think
that's true that's probably exactly what
happened wild huh um that's sad though
huh sucks which is the friend that had
the party in the picture there or no I
think I'll show you the picture of the
guy not him that's the one that passed
away I think this is the one that was
scien he's Mur he's a Mur I'm just Kidd
HIV scientist did you know that was a
profession no but that makes me think
the gay stuff which I it's so I don't
know man yeah Mak think it but not
guaranteed I'm just
like story yeah it sounds like something
something happened in terms of like they
were doing something and Fentanyl
happened I mean why would this guy drag
his cuz he bought the cocaine he bought
the coke he gave them the blow that's
murder all of a sudden all three guys
die he's responsible I see what you're
saying so all a sudden he goes Oh no I
got to drag these guys outside pass out
I'm going to pretend that I've been
asleep for two days that's what happens
but just this is just our thoughts we we
don't know for anything yeah but that's
that's so cops when you try to do this
with the FBI they're very they've been
around like if you think you get away
when you say you have people who are FBI
guys who really are just detectives have
been doing this for 20 years good luck
with your you're not going to fool him
you're not going to fool him well that's
tough the truth is just hard to cover on
all that kind of stuff you can't get
away with it I thought to myself the
only way you could murder someone to get
away with it it' have to be just a total
stranger yeah you'd have to be in the
it'd have to just be like you randomly
went to a thing and just you know but
who would want to do that it's a bummer
you have to be a crazy person so I I do
remember the initial reports saying that
uh the cops said that they they were
100% sure that it was not like a
homicide but they're still investigating
but this is uh what I highlighted here
this is what they saw when they open the
door to the house or the
place do you see oh my God he had an
empty wine glass in hand he was in his
box like what's up guys yeah but
apparently he put water in the wine
glass like you know like after being
hung over were they outside still uh
that I don't know yeah told the news
alley that the stemware contained water
had been refilled after being used to
drink the wine yeah yeah yeah so what I
I in my mind I'm just thinking like he's
like what's up guys what's going on
what's the problem like uh did you have
a party where's your friends they're all
Frozen in the back I just fell asleep I
but then I heard the you know in the
story like the wife or not the wife the
fiance found the body first so maybe
like she found the body called the cops
and then the guy answered the door with
the I don't know ex it's really weird
yeah he's like that party was days ago
it was days have you talked to your
friends no I've been asleep for 2
days crazy the guy doesn't work for a
living nuts yeah sleep for two days you
born model winning Miss Japan yeah so
thisit's identity this just happened
yeah damn what she's born in Ukraine so
she's she's not Japanese at all she's
like
disqualified so that's why there's a
debate right now about like ident
identity and how you know people I don't
find any of them attractive including
Ukraine I I don't know so I don't really
care really BR none of them no but
should she even be allowed to be in the
race you're telling me she identifies as
no no so she was since she was born
there born in Ukraine culturally she is
since 5 years old but then lived in
Japan since then and naturalized was
naturalized Japanese Citizen and then
but she ended up winning Miss Japan
which is kind of like an argument here
yeah no she shouldn't disqualified
you're not Japanese oh come on dude what
do you mean you're so mean well she's
still Japanese she grew up there that's
like Brian cuz Brian was born in the
Philippines that's like Brian being Mr
Philipp yeah makes no because if you're
an American and you happen to come from
Italy your ancestry is Italy but you
grew up in America you're still going to
be Contender from his America I mean
she's a naturalized Japanese
citizen but born in muddies it up you
know no she's a Japanese citizen so you
should be able to run from Miss Japan
you don't have to Bean Japanese
featured absolutely I don't know I feel
it it's a little weird I don't I don't
think so okay so you would so then so
then I guess if you're a naturalized
Japanese citizen you've got to look
quote unquote Japanese good luck with
that no just being born just being born
there not naturalized naturalized means
I was naturalized in America I'm
DNA is not Japanese minute hold on
you're M you're you're you're a
naturalized American citizen if you
played to sport for the Olympics you
represent America [__] you don't
Kore Korea and America born in Korea not
if you're not if you're [__] do if
you're and if you're an American citizen
here's what would happen you win the
American Gold Medal and we go that's our
guy chin the American but then when you
die and they drum up your bones they
that's a Korean right how do you get
this
americ am Steal This American it's not
really weird it's just weird because
it's another country it's definitely not
weird in our country if a woman looked
was Chinese and she of of ethnic Chinese
ethnicity and she want to Miss America
she'd be American because she's an
American citizen yeah but no but I see
here's the thing I have no problem with
this woman being in pageants why is she
going over there winning on the
Japanese all taller and [__] yeah she's
going on't right H why she winning why
is she winning with her Western features
the size of my tits and they go this
isn't
fair with your with your buom we have
Japanese tits she's like yeah well I
lived here for a long time let me get
some more pictures of her let me see
some more pictures let's see what she's
what she she got a huge ass all the
Japanese ladies are like this isn't fair
yeah Ukrainian women are pretty gorgeous
I had her pictures earlier
Carolina Shino there she's even got a
Japanese name I mean come on dude from
what you guys think she shouldn't be a
be able to win no she doesn't she's not
Japanese you've got to be [__] citizen
oh so she has to be so okay wait so so I
get it so I guess the criteria would be
you have to look Japanese so do they
bring out a ruler and measure it's not
about the looks it's not the looks what
do you mean it's not about the looks
She's there's a difference between what
you are and where you grew up listen you
racist son of a [__] no there's a
difference between what you are and
where you grew up that's like that's
like being K okay I see so hold on what
about so how does this apply to America
world all Americans however okay so how
does this apply since we're not
indigenous people okay so we come from
different different right so there's
Germany right Germany and a girl from
Cameroon has lived there since she was
five she should not be allowed to be in
Miss Germany's P because she looks
cameroonian she doesn't look German she
shouldn't be allowed just like if a hot
German chick who grew up in America
actually an Asian wellit I'm trying to
find a good one
like I'm just saying like you couldn't
just go over there and go oh well let me
in if you're a citizen you're you're
considered ridiculous these pageants got
to stop she's hot don't get me wrong she
is I want to see I want to see the body
I want to see if she's super skinny or
what she Carolina Shino I like her face
very skinny all right I'm a big fan
moving on what's the next thing you got
I can't believe Ken didn't agree with us
on that know I'm shocked what do you
think schnaz oh my God call Shaz SAS you
know what I'm I'm going to wait till you
call me by my name sonaz I'd like to
hear your uh I I'm on the fence with
that one you don't care either way I'm
on the fence another political answer I
yeah what do you want me to say I would
like you to say your opinion I think
it's a little odd because she wasn't
born there right and obviously she looks
a little different so how did you guys
get actually almost looks like she's not
Asian Japanese cut to 5 years later how
did you guys actually meet and how many
kids you have four we had an argument
about Miss America Jeff was um guesting
on fighter in the kids hey I stand by my
position yeah she's not Japanese you
don't get to be in the Japanese contest
guys you're so
mean John Stewart return to the Daily
Show huh yes so after Trevor NOA left in
2022 it's just been like a revolving
door of randoms and John St says I will
come back for this election time cool I
never car that much for uh I love John
Stewart one of my favorite Americans I
love him never car that much for um what
what's that he was okay I just never it
was like he had some big shoes to fill
yeah I agree I mean he did a good job
for that but there's no one like John
Stewart John Stewart's not only like
great on camera but he actually gives a
[__] he's amazing he might have ruined
politics you think yeah cuz it as as
much as we've profited from it and as
much as he's so talented and
entertaining and Brilliant and
it has created this
new since he started The Daily Show it's
created this whole new like politics is
entertainment now no and it's like like
everybody's going to get their
information from a show on Comedy
Central about politics you know like
John Oliver will write Like This
brilliant six-minute hit piece on Donald
Trump and because it's so funny yeah and
satirical and great people are quoting
that as real politics and people really
believe the it's just kind of mucked up
the political world and it's weird for
me to say that as a comedian but it's
just a little it's a little
gross yeah well but I I think John
Stewart asked some pretty great
questions to all all sides and I
appreciate that I gotta listen to him
more um wait what was there there was
something else let me see the would you
be fine with John Stewart winning Miss
Japan there you go he's been there
multiple times where I draw the line
unless he was a citizen he's been there
multiple times he's willing to
transition to uh to a citizen I didn't
know that but I would vote for him for
that yes this was just a funny clip I
found uh this high school kid does not
like this ref's decision and this is
what he does is this old I think I've
seen
[Applause]
this I've seen this yeah
no one knew what to do they were like oh
my
God uh you're that's a big problem for I
I would [__] that kid would pay a
real price for that I have to set an
example you I heard that that ref said
something bad about Jada pinket
Smith so we're going to allow it uhuh so
we are going to allow it we have the
same car you have a Tesla why I got a
little toy car like this oh yeah yeah
well you know it's very similar now we
have a mine has a battery though it's
cool wait what was the next one sorry
I'm distracted by no it's good it's
another flight issue so a flight was
canceled minutes before takeoff cuz
these guys are sitting in their seats
look out the window and notice bolts are
missing from the wing on a Virgin
Atlantic flight so fun and they
literally had to get in there like right
before and just fix it wow it's it's
terrifying yeah well why was the
passenger the one who knows I mean how
many bolts do you really need for the
wing enough to where they stopped the
flight yeah was well no they only sto
the flight cuz these guys are going hey
there's no some bolts missing were they
on their way to uh the Miss Japan
pageant oh yeah you know I well they and
they might have been the judges a good
question yeah it's a I'm all I'm doing
is asking questions we're just doing the
Harding questions I don't know what
Brendan's not here we're here to do the
the Dirty Work dirty ask some questions
hold on female dentist strips naked let
me see that oh my God this is at an
airport in Jamaica oh what's her problem
um watch the video wow seems like a long
video just give no give it
a what did a woman tackle or something
what a psycho uh is she on mushrooms
or that's what I thought she has to be
on drugs or
something gross oh God she's grabbing
his she tries to get his gun or his dick
she's having a but look what she's going
to do with her hands here in a minute
she's having a major
breakdown man I thought my rock botom
was bad major
breakdown I mean that's a that's a
psychotic break yeah yeah it's very sad
she was in Jamaica vacationing with
friends and her family and friends said
she's been having some personal
challenges yeah she she you know that's
very sad because she had a mental
breakdown and we should all be
compassionate that's you're right but
those titties aren't having a mental
breakdown am I
right no no Jeff no no Jeff that's not
that's not the takeaway Jeff that's not
the I look for the positives no I know
Jeff that's just not the takeaway I'm
going to ask you Jeff I'm going to have
to ask you to not take that as a
takeaway I just thought they Jeff she
was being a little cooky but but I think
that the uh the all I'm saying boobs
looked good they did look good yeah
that's a sad situation yeah uh what are
the personal challenges did they list
those no was she like a bad breakup or
something or yeah I would say it's
either iasa gone bad or chemical and
balance yeah
that's she's having a that's that's
hospitalization where we have to talk to
you and see if you're okay I have
thought to myself sometimes in TSA at
the airport I'll think to myself like
what would someone like if they're just
sick of this they just strip down they
go there you go look nothing on me
because like you you before be like take
that jacket off and you're like all
right and then they're like all right
actually you need the sweatshirt off too
you're like eventually you just want to
be like all right yeah but if you did
that to me and I was a TS a agent I
would be
like nice try bend over oh yeah peel
that peach she wanted she wanted them to
do that too there there was was going
that was very strange that that's a
terrible day in there if you want to see
it oh man she just went crazy she tried
to get his gun she went crazy was it
that or was she trying to grab his his
piece I think she just went crazy well
that's what I call a dick you know a
piece his actual piece I call mine do
you have do you ever do you have a name
for your dick no not not possibility or
no I call it the hammer really yeah I be
like yeah I got a hammer congratulations
that's a cool name though right yeah you
working with a piece yeah all right I
like it dude
she's not happy about this proud of
you um all right well that's that's it
yeah good no more current events we have
more but if you guys are no more what
are we what you we can't end on the
crazy lady I want to hear the guy's
opinion on this one all right oh the
Hugh Hefner yeah go ahead hit us with
the okay I want opinions so Hugh
Hefner's Widow has a memoir coming out
and she's changing her last name back to
Harris but you notice here it still says
Hefner on the bottom of the book here
she's saying she had no idea that he was
the misogynist that he was she was
completely blindsided and she just
couldn't believe what she was getting in
herself involved in and that she was
hypnotized the whole she she so full of
[__] actually you know
what I believe
her really so listen to this it do I
think Crystal Hafner is completely
looking for money and looking just to
get and you get us to talk about it and
trying to sell books yes do I think
she's Money Motivated Fame motivated and
maybe should be judged for those things
yes she came into the picture so late
yeah she was not there for the hey day
she was not even there for the girls
next door she was there for the money
she's AB yeah which you can judge that
but I don't think I I think if she's
going to be like I thought he was just
like a sweet old guy I didn't know that
he had been a I kind of buy that a
little bit she came in and she kicked
Holly out yeah she's so full of [__]
atend this a mercenary H Holly got the
boot and she moved in this is a
mercenary she married had tons of
girlfriends no but she's a mercenary she
she married a she married a 90-year-old
man knowing he was going to die it was a
strategic play it all about money and
this now is about saying I didn't know
so you were a victim you were a grown
person and you were a victim you had no
idea that what he was what what are you
talking about no so you just you have
you don't know how to take
responsibility for yourself but you're
very good at figuring out a way to make
a lot of money off that I think she's an
opportunist and and and very vapid
surviving Playboy and finding myself I
know it's got to be tough for you hun
compared to all the other people take a
look at the world pick up a newspaper or
history book and and you realize how
good you've got it you had to live in
the Playboy Mansion with all that money
and and those looks it must have been so
hard you had to survive the Playboy
thing oh my you poor [__] I'll share
a story that might go viral yeah so when
I uh started uh when I first came to Los
Angeles my girlfriend was Sarah
Underwood who was Playmate of the Year
in 2008 or 2007 playm of the year but I
was uh I dated her in 2008 met her on
Last Comic Standing we had a long
relationship together you could put
Sarah Underwood Jeff
die uh wow and uh this was the you know
so I was with her uh so we were at the
Playboy Mansion a lot we uh you know we
we I was in that I wasn't in that world
but I was I I she talked a lot she told
a lot of stories and listen to this if
you want to hear about behaving and you
want to talk about like we're going to
retroactively judge people for their
decision making uh Holly Bridget and
Kendra if they didn't want to spend the
night with Hugh Hefner uh what they
would do was just go find young girls
like in Santa Monica or on the pier or
in these things uh including Crystal
Hefner and go hey you want to go to the
Playboy Mansion these girls go this
chick's a reality star like I've watched
her on this TV I'm gonna get to hang out
with h they'd go get cocktails with them
at like a little beach bar knowing
they're going to pwn this young girl off
on Hugh Hefner that night young girls
young and very you can look at a girl
and go ah this girl wants fame or this
girl's looking they basically prayed on
these young girls the way a modeling
agency or men or douchebags do have no
doubt and would take him back to the
Playboy Mansion very exciting for a
young girl to be getting to hang out
with Kendra getting to hang out with
Bridget or Holly to get to go back to
the Playboy Mansion like there's
millions of people in the world who have
never gotten that that would want that
and these girls are like I must have hit
the jackpot yep then around dusk when
Holly wants to go f off with whoever
she's hanging out with and Bridget wants
to hang out with their boyfriend Nick or
Kendra wants to go hang out with her
current boyfriend they would just leave
these young girls with an old creepy
dude and you know if everybody is so
interested in Sharing every little
detail of someone's past even after
they're [__] dead what does Holly
Madison and Kendra and Bridget have to
say about literally feeding this man
these things and now they're all
capitalizing off of his death shame on
them and she was part of that those
those two little blonde twins that were
always bopping around were like young
and all the older Playmates and all and
the and the The Girls Next Door were
like yeah if we you know if we bring
them up there to Hue then we don't have
to we don't have to I've I've heard them
say those sentences you've heard them
say that yeah and also my girlfriend
would tell me uh Sarah would tell me
things like those stories but then also
other things that I won't share but I
was around when I heard those things I
believe it it's terrible they're mercen
now she so I ping themselves as victims
Stockholm Syndrome oh really yeah and I
don't think Chris was a victim by any
means but if I I could see that she came
in towards the end when it was like you
know well what she didn't get glamorous
Hugh Hefner there was a time where Hugh
Hefner was like a badass he was cool he
had a pipe he looked kind of hot he was
like the king of La he's like hanging
out with Marilyn Monroe like the guy was
a stud she got old let's play checkers
by the pool once a week and get bring me
my milk guy so you know she's up
whatever D Coogan had the funniest
[__] uh the funniest bit about Hugh
Hefner this is like 20 years ago he's
like yeah what do you think of these
young girls and Hugh hner goes they're
lucky and he's like lucky lucky he's
like and he was doing his thing where
they was like he he would have these
Viagra like Tic Tacs and he be taking
him you get lucky girl she's like he's
got great pubic
girl hair in his ass and trying to throw
up and the other girls holding the
[__] it was one of the greatest bits
I've ever seen in my life but it was
like yeah that that he was he was 90
something yeah and I'm tired of this
generation pretending like all these
women have been so wrong take a little
accountability get the [__] you knew
exactly what you were doing of course so
it's like yes I do feel bad you're
probably put in some terrible situations
and the The Temptations and all put
themselves in those saying there's a
little give and take but for the most
part you take some responsibility you
made you made money yeah you wanted to
be with this guy like for what for
clout
see everybody is out for a dollar it's
sex for sale don't act like you're
you're a victim you made those decisions
you were a grown person shut up I
thought the audition was at 1000 p.m.
with cocktails when he was wearing a
towel in his hotel room yeah right how
could I have known that that's not how
show biz worked unbelievable idiots I
think that's a good thing to end on that
was good Jeff die yeah coming in the day
my brother love you man Brendon we love
you buddy yep brenon we love you uh and
prayers guys please for Brenan and uh
that's my brother so um yeah I'm I'm
staying very positive yeah but it's been
a tough one been a tough one oh yeah
some where are you going to be uh this
weekend I'm in uh in Nebraska then I go
to De Mo uh that's all this weekend and
then I'm in Austin I'm shooting my
special on February 9th and 10th in
Nashville Tennessee at Z's yep oh no uh
at this it's a separate venue is it up
there uh the electric Jane which jelly
role played before um but then the
weekend before that I'm in Austin Texas
at Cap City comedy club I'm also at
Mothership at night nice so come see uh
come see me there also I have a podcast
that just came out really with Josh
Nelson our boy yeah uh it's called
everybody's got a price check it out uh
it's a very very fun podcast to listen
to you would be too wealthy to be a
guest the guests need to be broke and
willing to do things for some money I
love it but you could come on and then
you could maybe offer up some of your
money to see people do things okay I'll
do that like everybody's got a price
check it out go to youtube.com backf
Good Louisville Comedy Club everybody
March 1 and two um and then uh Bricktown
Comedy Club March 89 I like the way
that's Comedy Club so that's Tulsa
Oklahoma so I'm in Louisville Kentucky
I'm in Tulsa Oklahoma I'm in Oklahoma
City Oklahoma get your tickets brian.com
let's go